today is a wonderful day indeed
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
it's been a long time since I've played
this game in a serious let's play
capacity and today is special because
not only am able to play a game that I
really really love but this game is now
fully released back when I did my
original series on this they didn't even
have water working correctly and now
they are out of early access with all
the bells and whistles you could
possibly want so I'm going to start a
brand new game a survival game and wait
a minute I don't know what this is
tera meets all the requirements for
duplicate 11 hold notes prizes ideal
location for a first attempt
establishing called me well okay
Oceania is quite stable in research with
with Meniere's but covered in a
saltwater ocean who rhyme a frigid
location marked by in hospitably low
temperatures throughout rhymes low
temperature will to make finding water
and establishing farms or ranches
problematic however the wide spectrum of
minerals and cool environment could lead
to thriving industry o ver Dante a lush
location with rich and wildlife and
life-sustaining resources establish a
foothold in VAR Dante will be
challenging do the roost food and oxygen
options however abundant biological and
mineral resources should afford
excellent long term growth on board yeah
colonizing our brewery will require
careful planning right from the start
because if its lack of metals finding
biological oceans is a must
Vulcania would be perfect if it wasn't
for the volcano Badlands rocky terrain
poses no threats but sparse resource
ability will make expansion
technological process challenging Oh a
radio temperatures are a radio are much
higher than expected while resources are
abundant maintaining food an instructor
will be difficult as your colony warms
oh haha a wide outer ground desert will
post temperatures threats and strain
resources of a colony on Oh asses ass
however surviving the challenge should
present great industrial opportunities
ok good oh my god oh my god I don't know
if I should do a normal one or if I
should do a not Armel
and also hate myself for doing anything
that would be bad you know I want to do
a different one and I feel like large
boulders large glaciers on Oceania I
feel like that's an interesting thing
game setting oh well you know I don't
want to do that yeah okay let's go for
it baby this is this unexplored
territory I didn't even know that was
new in the game we're gonna die we are
going to go to our immediate death
everyone who's a part of this colony
will hate me cuz they're going to die oh
[ __ ] nevermind
whoops were sorry but it seems your game
has encountered an air of [ __ ] we died
before we even began okay good great I
broke the game before I even got into it
shouldn't it die I shouldn't have done a
lot of things is the thing I shouldn't
have done pretty much anything
magma channels and frozen core well that
doesn't seem good that seems like two
peas in a pod that ain't gonna work out
too good for me
here we go hope I don't crash hey are we
okay
Oh interior decorator noodle arms Oh
interesting
Oh interesting Oh interesting
all right we need a digger loves digging
no taste
irritable bowel that's not that bad but
we've got our minor and then we need a
operator off logic reactions to floral
scents oh okay well that's not so bad
iron gut that's good that's what we're
looking for here that's that's exactly
what we're going for
and then we need a builder reroll
mee-mah mee-mah mee-mah was a little
slow but that's okay okay you're not
gonna be named Nicola you're gonna be
named you're your bull your beard ooh
and this is nice she could sure alright
that's you could chew that's beer do and
that's me ma is the name of the colony
is going to be the suave Brig
no loveliest gang outrageous Hospital
ill committee Oh ill committee would be
the great name for a
and was picton Pigpen thanks good Pigpen
I like Pigpen
I welcome to Pigpen cool I like that
that's good Pigpen
okay all right let's do this SUSE guys
kaput
oh look at this ideal placement watch
the stress of all can colonization ever
did okay so if you don't know about
oxygen not included it's a survival base
building game that involves a lot of
crap so one of the other self-imposed
rules here is you have the ability to
pause in this game
I'm not going to pause ever pausing is
that one thing that makes you stop and
think but the one thing that I want to
do in this endeavor I've played this a
lot I'm pretty good at this is I don't
want to stop and think I'm gonna try to
always play it at like medium speed
occasionally I'll go too fast speed if
they're like sleeping or something but
for right now I want to go medium speed
I'm gonna get them going I want to get
everything started and I do not want to
pause so this will be the only time that
I pause and if I ever pause then I
deserve to be punished
alright cool good really glad we got
that so we're just gonna keep this going
and I'm just gonna try to build as
quickly as possible
build as quickly as plunk able then I'm
gonna be relatively okay we need a door
because we need to go up and then we're
gonna need there's a lot of goodies here
and there's a lot of goodies here a lot
of algae up here which we're gonna need
for oxygen so in case it wasn't obvious
there ain't no frickin oxygen in this
land
there's none oxygen it don't work that
way they just don't give you [ __ ] so I'm
gonna put this here I'll put some oh I
don't even have that Reece yes I do yes
oh that's what I get for not pausing
okay it's good real hard to not pause by
the way pausing is like in my blood I
really love what is this what is this
select hat you don't have a hat what is
this rocket piloting be still my space
loving heart well you could chew what do
you think you're doing so what was I
doing
okay so skills priority schedule I don't
have a schedule I'm gonna give them an
extra morning bath time
maybe more down yeah give them some
morning downtime that's the moral that
we need this is gonna be good okay so I
need
okay pitcher pump that's what I need
we're gonna get that there yeah it's
gonna be good let's make that a priority
we got to get that going else we're
never gonna be able to do anything we're
also gonna need birds with the bird oh
[ __ ] I put that in the wrong place all
right well I wasn't thinking but there
here we go
why can't you breathe and then look at
this a bowl of fruit that's red eye
waters weed seed we see the initial
phases of the game just to get real
scientific about it is not dying that's
like the number one priority and all
this is to not die it is so beginner
mistake to die early on in the game
not many people know that you're trying
to avoid the possibility of being dead
so long as you can do that everything's
gonna be good
Oh yellow alert I didn't know yellow
alert was a thing I like yellow okay no
oxygen defuser built what's an oxygen to
few did they finally make this not take
power does this not require power are
they yanking my dog all right so I got
to start planning right away for the
different things that I'm gonna need the
different like levels that we're gonna
need what I want to do what I always try
to do is I try to make the box around
the thing longer thing I try to make
that like a nice area for beds and stuff
because it affords a really nice bonus
for decorations so if I can have that
that's good oh these lazy sacks a
crapper thinking that they actually get
time off for shame for shame everyone
else that was just a clever ruse that I
put I put that base in there I did not
want to put that there
I am not thinking clearly in any
department so I actually have no idea
what I'm doing half the time they've got
their job I have my job we're gonna need
a station we need a research station so
we're gonna make this the research
station area
but uh but about about oh it doesn't it
does need power I suspected as such I
suspected it I knew it I knew it
couldn't be that good they wouldn't give
that thing without power but was they
even thinking of course they wouldn't oh
and what am I even thinking I forgot to
get an oxygen flow chip Oh fluid
dynamics is weird in this game it's not
weird it makes total sense but nature's
weird and life is weird so why wouldn't
this game simulating life be weird I
didn't make an oxygen flow channel what
I'm going to do is I'm just gonna make
this is gonna be the oxygen flow and
that's gonna be it cuz you need to have
space for the oxygen to go up and down
or else it's never gonna be good manual
generator battery wire station research
station wire bada-bing bada-boom the
reason I'm a little panicked is because
if you don't set up the right stuff in
the early game you are screwed and
there's no other way to explain it other
than that you are screwed if you don't
set things up right from the very
beginning and try to get things going
from the very beginning you are going to
die and not just you but you could chew
beer do
Mima they're all dead they're all gonna
die and I ain't gonna let them die cuz I
ain't about that I ain't about letting
them die so I'm not gonna do that and
also I'm not gonna be an idiot and I'm
not gonna build my outhouses after I
delete him I'm gonna build them first
and then I'm going to delete the other
ones cuz that would be smart and I am
smart also don't ask me why I did three
I've literally never done three ladders
in a row before and I don't know why I'm
doing it now but it seems and feels like
a good idea also I really need that I
really need all that oxygen up there so
I need this flow to happen lower by the
way can I mention that things are
looking so smooth aren't you eating
there you could chew what's wrong with
you
whatever you guys are so fun you guys
are great I love you guys guys that's
weird
see if Ida deleted them they wouldn't
have built the other ones and then I
would be swimming and [ __ ] it would be
literally everywhere but right now
there's not they can't wash their hands
though so that's me bah where are you
getting up why are you getting up why
are you waking up
what unrest 'add there was a light left
on you kidding me my strategy is danda
my strategy is dead because they're
light oh now my strat my six strat no no
I thought that I could've gettin the
decoration bonus I'm an ass okay
whatever we're gonna do without the six
strat we're just gonna make a big old
Smorgasburg of cots up here and that's
what it's good there's gonna be the cot
room and that's it because we're
uncultured swine who don't actually
deserve to have anything nice in their
life that's what we are isn't that right
Iike to call any achievement earned hey
what did I get
hey have at least one toil in the colony
and a bed forever I pick baby so let's
not destroy that yeah because we don't
have the means by which to recycle so
there's gonna be a lot of people if we
do that so let's not have kind of a
personal policy of mine not have why did
I make this too wide
this is too long's an oddly-shaped okay
anyway can we get some gosh-darn power
going because if we don't get any
gosh-darn power we're not gonna get any
gosh darn science and we need science
meemaw I know you're too stupid to
understand but meemaw
there is database update hmm I've
synthesized enough who's to print a new
duplicate all I have to do is choose a
new point really good-looking skills on
it what no you haven't
no you haven't reached the temporal
terror sends a duplicate on one-way
mission to the first star map Desmond
Bardo name on excuse Emma can you build
this gosh-darn
beer do stock you do [ __ ] you you piece
yellow alert
I like that yeah yellow alert hell yeah
hmm that's cool I do like that a lot
that's pretty cool I you know I'm about
that I am all about that that's pretty
neato burrito guys I I don't know if
you've ever had burritos but that's
neato new friend Oh what care
[Music]
you're back arbor acorn the seed of an
arbor tree I don't know I know about
Arbor Day I don't know it an arbor tree
is or an arbor ACORN
I see well that you know I'm not gonna
do because I think I need another person
first okay bottomless stomach probably
fine athletics is good that's good oh
but you can't be named Nisbet you gotta
be named since you got twinkle toes on
my name you tinkle toots yeah tinkle
puss I get any wrinkled toots oh look
it's over
alright buy a CI the tinkle touch here
hey are you doing skill point of this
gonna danger tinkle toads is gonna
tinker boots
school boy all right let's research hey
hey look that looks similar hey that
looks pretty good
fancy let's uh let's get food going cuz
that's always a safe bet and I do want
to get a lot of wrangled up animals I
want to basically have a prison for
animals what do they call those zoos
yeah I want to have one of those alright
is this enough oxygen for everybody are
we doing okay on oxygen that's not
oxygen yeah it looks pretty good I think
we need a better co2 trap eventually but
I don't have to worry about that right
now I don't think it's ever gonna get to
a problem unless it becomes so
compressed that people's ears stop
popping which is definitely a
possibility it this happened before
so let's actually let's try to do some
preventative crap about it let's go
straight down not that far and let's do
this is just like a busy project for
them to do in the meantime I don't want
to have them forget things to do you
know at any given time but I guess it's
break time now so I guess we don't
actually have to work I guess we're done
you know I guess we're just you know
I'll I'll be over in the corner just
slapping my dick around while you guys
do whatever the hell you were thinking
of doing so I guess we're all good here
thanks alright think'll toots I'm gonna
call you tinkle Tish tinkle push that's
a better name I'll call you tinkle push
okay we need to start thinking about
expanding and these can be destroyed now
this can be just set to the right I
think cuz I just want people to wash on
the way out actually let's do both
porque no los dos both right do--the
yeah Dothraki alright guys get to work
buddies we don't have the compost heap
but we will show that's going to be good
hey that batteries gonna start storing
power hey that's gonna use power but
that's ok look things were looking up
thanks for doing good are we doing
temperature wise temperatures like the
other thing that you got to worry about
a lot temperatures like always going to
be a problem because it's like the law
of thermodynamics everything's trying to
reach equilibrium but everything just
gets hotter and hotter and then
everything gets colder and colder
because everything is surrounded by the
vacuum of space yes we are on an
asteroid and what that means is that we
were going to die isn't that cool it's
pretty cool to me alright so those are
done now they're spitting out polluted
oxygen cuz I am an [ __ ] why didn't I
just put that down here this would be
such a better place for that listen I've
got my big brain is just so big that I'm
going to big brain all over this this
makes so much sense right that makes
sense I don't need two of those but it
looks good so if it looks good then it
must be good right ok we don't have
anything else to build so I can't do
anything until they build things well
that's good that's great you guys hurry
the hell up maybe I should go ahead and
build some tasteful memorials because
I'm pretty sure that these guys are
gonna die well maybe not these guys but
people are definitely gonna die tinkle
Tish
pickle dish might die are we doing on
research not enough come on come on come
on we gotta research go go go we can
destroy these now well I mean not yet I
guess cuz the wires aren't there but
alright you know it's it's fine why the
wires not connected but alright you know
that's that's fine that's that's fine
yeah what that's it's totally fine I'm
not power and anything and having two of
those just means the two people are
always going to be on those
I don't think that's a good idea let's
let's we're gonna redo some things here
this is how we're gonna do it this makes
sense this makes a lot of sense except
that everybody's going to take a break
God you know I know we're missing a
research station I set it to build why
did I destroy it I've said that to
myself that I don't destroy anything
until it's built and then I do the thing
and then I don't do listen I blame me
mom I'm just gonna say it
I think Mimas sabotaging with her
non-scientific ways I think this is just
an elaborate scheme for me Maude to try
to bring us down try to bring us all
down and I hate that this is uneven
there's a lot of things that I dislike
and it's all because I wasn't able to
pause so I blame that and I take no
responsibility for myself and my own
actions but I fully am aware that I am
probably at full hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey sleepyhead
hey wake up do I have to do yellow alert
again because I will I will do a yellow
alert I will literally do a yellow alert
now I feel bad because yellow alert is
this is taking a long time to build that
thing can you oh also I interrupted your
break I guess but you know frankly I
think that you guys might have deserved
that but whatever it's fun anyway let's
uh let's focus on even ending this out
cuz this is apparently the most
important thing that I have to do now
there we go now isn't that better now
isn't everyone happy there we go now we
don't have as much oxygen flow that is
true down this channel but hey I think
two is probably more than enough right
it's only one of the main aqueducts
going up and down my base so how
important could it really be I fine why
is it yeah why is that one low I don't
need that to be one lower I need that to
be one better let's dig this out first
oh no no no no no well there's no
rescuing you guys I I wish they didn't
do that when they drown cuz
oh hey but food though I feel bad not
that bad but I feel pretty bad
I do I do I do feel bad I really feel
bad I do okay insufficient oxygen
generation and we got research okay
power regulation probably important
employment oh yeah uh but no mm I guess
plumbing right plumbing fruitless
annotations and all the other things
converse rust what is rust
since when is rust a thing rust like the
game I don't know I don't know what
you're talking about very strange I
don't know what rust is and I don't know
what to do about anything if rust comes
my way I think I'll die I think if I
have to deal with rust I would die okay
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna in my
my dioxide trap I'm gonna make this be
the oxygen producing landing zone I
don't have the air tiles yet but I think
for now I think what I'm going to do is
I'm just gonna put four here I don't
need to go overboard that's something
that I learned I do not need to go
overboard with the algae cuz it's just
not that important especially right off
the bat it's not that important compost
however that is important so what I'm
gonna do is I'm also gonna make this the
compost area cool right probably I don't
know I'm gonna put you in a box and then
when I'm able to make that be actually
airtight that's what that will be but
for now that's just going to be a box I
don't know why I'm making doors but it
feels good there we go nice yes yeah
I like things being organized closed off
that's what I like sue me what did you
what what did you get what what happened
he what do you just get his skill while
you slept
Oh skill boy oh my God look at your to
Dueling I can actually see what you have
to do you could choose yes you're my
miner correct you're my miner so you are
all about digging that's your job you
could
you're all about that and I believe in
you
all right cool anyway so far so good
this is actually coming together quite
well if you remember my attempts at my
first few basis back in the day they did
not go to cured I feel awful
what is this skill points of Hill who's
got skill were you a builder I can't
remember if you were the Builder I think
you were the Builder me Mao were you the
Builder mee-mah mee-mah mee-mah
were you the Builder I think you might
yeah you would the Builder me ma you
would the Builder all right me ma o
beardo ok construction and beer do you
are tinkering
that's right beer do mmm it's going good
it's going real good all right cool so I
don't know what I'm gonna put up here
yet but now that I got this down here
that I don't have to worry about that as
much okay and then I'll once once I get
into it I'm gonna set the priorities and
schedules and all that and get the
vitals and yadda yadda but rough right
now they were okay and we're pretty good
on disease to these guys aren't being
too big of a jerk what I'm gonna do is I
need to make a dump for my polluted
water that is important so where would
be the best place for that
I can't pause so I got to think about it
as things are going I don't know why
people aren't doing this over here and
then I reach it no they can reach that
just fine yeah it's fine okay so for now
the dump I think doesn't have to be that
big I think the dump can be relatively
small there's slime over there so
naturally left oh oh there's a lot of
slime over here too there's a bowl of
fruit literally under polluted water
which is just disgusting I think what
I'm going to do is I'm actually going to
this will be the quote-unquote bathroom
eventually eventually I have no idea if
that actually it's gonna work but
eventually that'll be the bathroom let's
just do that for now and then this is
where I'm gonna put the dump which seems
really douchey because this is such a
nice this is like a pristine terrarium
of just lush life like there's animals
living down here there's just beautiful
creatures plant life this thing's going
I am going to flood you with piss water
you are going to be buried under my own
feces not mine my people's feces I'm
using the Royal version of the people's
feces it's a good thing so I'm gonna I'm
gonna use these acts
I don't even think I need to do that
what excuse me did we get research for
food I forgot I was doing food hey I
don't think we need a little person
immediately I don't think we need
another person I don't know what pips
are but I want them I don't think we
need another person right now
I think getting person would just be too
much I love the fact that it can give
care packages now that is super rad I
really like that and I appreciate that
and I think that's really cool I'm not a
hundred percent sure I want to get the
the pooper scooper to be down there when
this could also be good for farming area
I want to keep the farming generally
lower I don't even know if farming is
gonna be the same anymore am I gonna
have the same seeds for the seeds oh I
got blossom briar meal wood I've only
got one meal wood that's not a lot of
meal wood maybe they toned farming down
a lot they might've okay either way I
think what I got what I'm gonna do is
I'm actually gonna make it above I'm
gonna make it up here it's gonna be the
piss deposit or iam okay so also I just
remembered that I want the composters in
here
not necessarily in there and then I can
get the bottle empty years to be Roy
cheer Android cheer for symmetry because
somebody should I care about that anyway
that looking good is looking good that's
getting oxygen in there all right
we are doing pretty eh okay maybe there
should be like a germ thing here instead
of that that would be smart
now I'm thinking with my brain that's
how I do that's how I do it that's how I
do that's how I keep people alive hey
what did I do research yay okay let's do
instead of the rough stuff listen so
that let's do the ventilation get all
the basic [ __ ] stuff out of the way and
that way we can at least have like a
foothold in the world that is life oh
yeah I forgot these things also spit out
now now they don't just consume all the
water that's another rad cool thing
about it they don't just consume the
water they spit out polluted water like
it's not perfect but it's way better
because they used to just suck in water
and then it would spit out nothing but
now it spits up water polluted water
which I'm going to fix I will fix
eventually I will fix the water but
until I fix the water
going to be a little bit of a problem
well that's okay I like problems
problems are good and eventually I'm
gonna make this considering it's already
almost a natural like it's almost a
natural formation anyway I think what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to make this
be the water tank you know what I mean
like it's going to be eventually just
pure water tank I don't know if you need
to do double layer but I always have
water like break that [ __ ] from just the
pure weight of it so I'm not gonna take
any chances this is eventually gonna be
loose we're eventually gonna have this
year I like this whole not pausing thing
I don't usually play like this but not
enough materials what really I didn't
know that could be a thing I think we
need more metal well get more metal
there's metal up here what did I just
tell you to do alright whatever that's
good enough for now to get started in in
anyway so eventually that's gonna be the
thing that we do and hey you know how I
said I was gonna piss all over your
entire existence well there's some right
there but also you know right you know
okay you know I need food I need to work
on the whole food thing if I don't work
on the whole food thing I am going to do
the whole dying thing I need food okay
so let's think about growing food just
thinking about it doesn't mean we're
doing it we're just gonna think about it
you know what I mean
yeah we're just gonna think about it
just go think about it you know give it
a little bit of brain juice okay so
these guys got a lot of tasks to do so
I'm gonna put him on fast mode I don't
like being on fast mode because it lets
things spiral out of control and I won't
be able to do anything if things go
wrong but for now they've got a lot to
do I'm gonna let him go I'm gonna
twiddle my thumb's and do absolutely
nothing unless something goes horribly
wrong which it might I should also
probably prioritize this just a little
bit more this is more of an important
bill than the giant cup of water that we
don't necessarily need to have right now
I don't know why we're so focused on
having the giant tub of water ready when
in fact we have many other problems like
this which is another problem and then
the foods food also big priority gotta
get those I'm tempted to do yellow I
said I was gonna do nothing I'm gonna
step back
I should have put everything back
already
I feel like feel like I screwed it
they're not doing anything else besides
that so yeah that's that's the thing
cool we're gonna put some eel woods
no research focus uh we need a research
okay hey no we just got ventilation you
smart home duplicants can operate
buildings more quickly if the building
is lit the building is lit okay cool
I'll keep that in mind
um I need the airflow tile though and
pressure management first we will get
lighting eventually and this is lit
right now because of the light they're
so they're able to do that a little bit
better you guys need to stop sleeping on
the job I've got a lot of work to do and
you guys are not helping I want to
address something that I know is
probably being shouted in the comments
as much as possible I know there's
probably like an optimal way to play I
know this I'm aware there's probably
optimal ways of doing things in base
layouts in yada-yada I'm doing what I
know and I'm learning as I go
if I die then I die take a look at this
ladder right here notice how it looks
like a giant middle finger take that
with a grain of salt I mean I think that
beats a grab doing that gonna tell me
how to play if you're trying to backseat
game I will literally follow you to your
house and beat you with my own leg I
guess that means I'm gonna kick you oh
you need light I don't have that I'm not
researching that I should research that
let's research light I didn't know you
needed that you greedy bastard what
happens if we go all the way down here
and grab like some of the stuff down
here that's just sitting around we doing
food not good not good
okay we're not doing as good on food as
I thought we were gonna be we need food
like immediately
that's not like a number one okay we're
not doing nearly as good as I thought we
were gonna do
maybe my priorities haven't exactly been
in the right spot I don't know why I'm
doing triple level things and stuff like
that I don't know why I'm not doing do
smart but you know hey I'm just learning
dig out these sides you know that's just
as good air flow is doing triples why am
i doing triple ladders I have no idea
there's no benefit there is no benefit
to doing triple ladders I want to be
very clear about that there's no benefit
I don't know why I'm doing it and yet I
am okay let's get another person in here
yeah let's get another mouth
let's do that yeah let's do that water
water you can do that Wow look at Turner
holy crap look at Turner look at her
Turner's amazing I'm not gonna call you
Turner I'll call you turn-turn no I'm
sorry that's your name now Turner Turner
yeah
look at Turner go all right cool good I
don't know what you're gonna do Turner
you could be what are you good at I have
no I forget what even what you were good
at woodturner where are you there you
are skills athletics you can be the
deliverer oh you can be the SUP why our
supplier right that's that's probably
good for you yeah supply you shall be
the supplier you're gonna run and give
everybody everything and also the pout
what are you doing what what I'm sorry
what did you just do oh you can't be by
flowers you sneezed Oh cure it okay and
sneezed okay well not very cured are you
then a snoozed well maybe you shouldn't
go buy flowers you sneezed okay now that
that's there I should probably destroy
that one but it's too late now so I
guess I just have to live with my
choices in life okay so this is pretty
good this is going well why are you
doing nothing
why are you doing oh it's break time
alrights my bad okay so this is going
well this is good for right now I'm out
of time for this episode but this is a
good start
we could still die at any moment but
we've got some good but I'm gonna pause
just because I'm ending it here but
we've got ye kachou we've got beer do we
got me Mom we got tinkled push it a bit
Twinkle pushin and that just makes it
seem like she poops a lot we got turnt
nur this is our family and with this
family we will survive throughout the
apocalypse of this horrible place that
we have found ourselves we may just be
clones spat out by a DNA manipulating
pod but we are survivors and we are
gonna survive together so thank you
everybody so much for watching get ready
for another episode of this coming at
you real hot and heavy
I want to do a full playthrough of this
I want to see it to the end whether the
end is a bunch of graves on abandoned
asteroid in the middle of space soaring
through an infinite nothingness or or if
it's whatever the hell the ending of
this game is I want to see it so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know he thought down the comments
below and as always see you
[Music]
you